carnivores hunting blood and territory
Wars all in a raid eg family movie
African Cats alright know every earth
day Disney comes out with one of these
Discovery Channel s kind of movies in
fact I'm pretty sure they take footage
from Animal Planet or something I'm
gonna level with you is interesting is
you might think I am I'm actually quite
boring I'm one of the people who will
sit down and watch like the Discovery
Channel and Animal Planet when they're
having like an eight hour marathon of
whatever so I find this stuff really
interesting in African Cats
I found interesting and the movie is
voiced over by none other than samuel
l.jackson probably because morgan
freeman was busy so they were like hey
who better to voice-over and rated g
family movie than the guy who was in
snakes on a plane he does a good job i
mean let's face it it's not Oprah
African cats ultimately follows to lion
families and a cheetah family but the
funny thing is it's just nature doing
his thing so there are no good guys or
bad guys until samuel l.jackson tells
you that that's the bad guy and let's
face it he does there's his family of
lions in the north and Samuel Jackson's
all he owns the northern territories but
he is not content he wants the southern
territories that's right African cats is
a territory war Henry when the Lions
meet on the river you just imagine that
the Lions from the north are alike it is
he's all river what you doing in our
space oh you're just taking a drink what
you think is that a bar looks worn off
thank took the words out my mouth you
did go back to your King Tim coming
apparently Lions in Africa sound like
Jason Statham I don't know it's like
African cats gives you a new perspective
on the Lion King it's like you know how
it really runs now I mean these animals
are really fascinating it's cool to see
how their family mechanic works they're
defensive of their families and then you
know if one takes over the other one the
other one just goes away alright the
pride years now that's interesting to me
I want to know how these people get
these shots these shots are crazy I'd
love to be the guy but like you know the
bush on his back aren't the mud on his
face with the camera filming this stuff
that'd be the job right there cuz let's
face it these shots are awesome but I
couldn't do it because there are parks
for like you know a little baby dies or
something a little baby cat the
cameraman is just filming it like he's
gonna die I can't interfere how many
girls do you think you'd get after that
I lost my arm do hyena while saving a
baby cub done I mean personally I like
the Discovery Channel I like Animal
Planet I'm an animal lover myself so I
really liked African cats if you don't
like that stuff I mean it's not gonna be
your thing it's like not liking Star
Wars and expecting to like Star Wars
when you watch it it wouldn't make sense
however if you like that kind of stuff
you probably want to check out African
cads it's really cool I don't
need to dramatization though I imagine
kids do and it's rated G so kids are
gonna go see it I mean if you plot kids
in front of this without any
dramatization it's gonna be like when
their teacher shows them this kind of
stuff or as I used to call it an
elementary school naptime so I
understand why they have the
dramatizations with samuel l.jackson x'
boys kids need to be entertained so I
would say I would buy African Cats
even on blu-ray or I just buy life on
blu-ray like three times the prize in a
hundred times the hours but if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more